diversity in comics is an interesting
topic right now it's kind of a funny
situation and the reason why is because
I've been going through these news
articles looking at people who are I
guess looking at these these posts that
people are making you know talking about
oh you know comic book fans are lashing
out a diversity yet again and what I'm
seeing is this common theme that these
news articles are basically making the
case that we'll come and look fans are
against diversity because they're
inherently racist you know they're
against our Erie Williams because she's
a minority and they don't want to see a
minority succeed they're against the new
52 Wally West because he's a minority
and they don't want to see minorities
succeed that's stupid and that's
probably one of the most irresponsible
instances of journalism if you can even
college journalism but it's one of the
most irresponsible instances of
journalism that I've ever I've ever
heard of or ever seen in any form of
fashion the reason why comic book fans
are so outraged right now is because the
characters they're invested in are going
away that's why they're mad what's
happening is people are saying well no
it's like they're taking the notion of a
character's race they're slapping it on
and saying no this is the reason why
they're angry it's not because the
characters change it's because they
changed into minorities no no the way
you won't know how I know that you want
to know how I know the fans were so
outraged that their characters changed
the new 52 DC's new 52 initiative in
2011 when DC came along and they said
everything stops except for Batman a
Green Lantern their histories kind of
stay intact but everything gets reset
whether you were a spider-man fan I'm
sorry Superman fan whether you were a
Wonder Woman fan regardless of what kind
of a fan you were people were lashing
out they were angry why because they
were invested because they started
reading comics of 1990 and they'd read
you know good Superman stories they'd
read bad Superman stories they'd read
great Wonder Woman stories they read bad
Wonder Woman stories but they were there
through thick and thin they were a loyal
fan to DC and now they felt betrayed
they felt cheated because all that
history was gone all that money they had
spent all that time they had spent
reading those characters was all gone
and they were angry they were they were
outraged about it
comics story I did a really really good
video where he talked about the notion
of diversity and one of the problems in
you dress'd
was this idea of force to diversity
basically saying yeah the heroes changed
and you have to read the new heroes now
DC did that and the new 52 sales did
amazing for like the first two issues of
most everything and then after that they
started dropping off the only exception
of that was like Justice League you know
some of the more premier titles or like
Batman as it was written by Scott Snyder
because it was done so well but for like
90% of their roster sales were falling
Swift and fast and DC trying to change
it up they said well we'll do
convergence we'll bring back some of
these old characters for a last hurrah
you know we'll bring back a well we'll
do like DCU where it's just stories that
revolve around you and there's no
continuity it's just it's wherever you
want it to be and it was confusing and
it was ridiculous and sales fell even
further so you know a DC dead DC said
stop the presses
rebirth we're literally gonna bring back
all these old characters that you loved
all those histories where those
individual characters are gonna be
intact and we're just gonna go from
there
we're just gonna keep on going on you
know and your buddy's gonna get the best
of both worlds and you know what
happened DC rebirth took the world by
storm it literally set the world on fire
in 2016 and crushed Marvel in sales
I mean obliterated Marvel there was one
point I think I remember if it was like
July or August or something like that
Marvel had three titles in the top 30
publications released in a month 3 DC
took everything else just throwing it
out there he was insane how well it did
and the reason why is because people
felt like they hadn't been cheated
anymore people got the histories and
those legacies back when if that's a fan
sat down and they said hey there's this
new 52 Wally West I don't like him it
wasn't because he was no minority it
wasn't because he was african-american
it was because when they started reading
Wally West they got into him because of
Justice League the cartoon show because
of Justice League Unlimited the cartoon
show because that was the Wally West
they loved because they were reading
Wally West when he first became the
flash they buried him ever since and
they just liked him coming become a book
fans or as resistant to change as your
average human being is I knew a guy at
the old job that I worked at who ate his
blueberry muffins for his morning snack
every morning at 9:30 on the dot didn't
miss a beat it was 9:30 a.m. you could
walk in he's sitting at that table and
he's eating his blueberry muffins woe
betide the poor soul who walked in there
and said hey man give me your blueberry
muffin sorry you can't eat those today
he would lose his like he would
freak all right that's just how people
are well I've been doing it this way for
20 years and
works and I don't really see a reason to
change it's always been that way in
comics that's nothing new
this will diversity initiative it adds a
new dynamic because of the fact of these
characters and minorities but the fact
that they are minorities is not why fans
are adverse to them in 1940 Jay Garrick
appeared for the very first time he was
the flash the first flash and he was the
flash for like eight years or something
like that and then as comics were
tanking because science fiction was
becoming more popular and so DC
cancelled his title and nineteen 1956
they introduced a new flash named Barry
Allen and you know what Jay Garrick fan
said Barry Allen sucks Barry Allen
doesn't either Big W Flash B Rihanna's
absolute trash I hate Barry Allen give
me Jay Garrick back now Barry Allen
sales did good for a little while but
then they started slumping off and so
what did DC do in 1961 they wrote flash
of two worlds and said here is Jay
Garrick now and then the sales the sales
of the flash comics started going back
up again because now Jay Garrick fans
got Jay in Justice Society of America
and they had wallet or they had Barry
Allen so now they had the best of both
worlds I can just kind of pick and
choose which one they wanted to read
this lasted for 19 years until 1985 when
Barry Allen died in crisis on Infinite
Earths
and Wally West who up until that point a
bit a sidekick was now the flash and he
know what Barry Allen fan said Wally
West sucks Wally West's trash Wally West
does not need to be the flash now this
lasted almost 20 years or less a little
bit longer than that actually lasts
until 2011
you know when Barry Allen was the flash
again the main flash the only flash with
the new 52 and you know what Wally West
fan said so it's not like it's something
brand-new it's not like it's something
that's just now happening it's something
that's been around this entire time but
comics torreón had a damn good point
when he said here's the issue
Iron Man fans sit down and they say yes
Tony Stark's done everything Tony Stark
found out he had a long-lost brother
Tony Stark found out he was adopted and
met his biological mom Tony Stark's been
part of the guardians of the galaxy Tony
Stark's pissed off a whole superhero
committee in civil war Tony Stark decide
to be a dick just for the sake of being
a dick and superior Iron Man Tony Stark
has succumbed to alcoholism and lost
everything and demon in a bottle Tony
Stark has done it all so they say yeah
sure okay there's only so much you can
do with a Tony Stark story but
just suddenly get rid of him make
something new that's literally your job
as a comic creator is not to rehash old
stuff but to make good stuff make new
stuff
use your imagination that's that's what
you're paid to do that's what we as
kullaberg readers buy comics for is new
things if that wasn't the case we'd all
just be reading crisis on Infinite
Earths over and over and over again in
DC Comics instead we get new and we get
incredible and we get amazing stories
and bidness did a great job with Iron
Man and he's kind of you know coming
back around again but the reason why
fans are upset is because they sit down
and they say but I've been reading Tony
Stark forever like I've been reading him
for so long I love Tony Stark I want to
see Tony so I come back and even if he
can't just let me kind of you know say
bye man it's been real don't just make
me read riri Williams because I don't
know her character I don't know anything
about her I don't know I can't relate to
her you know there's nothing about her
that I find interesting I find Tony
Stark interesting but I don't find her
interesting and so because of that now
they're like well why am I gonna read
Iron Man if Tony Starks not there they
don't have a reason to you not only that
they feel to you they feel like Marvel's
coming along and saying you need to read
this all right this is the only thing
you don't have any options here you
don't have any choices name me the last
time you were okay with somebody coming
along and telling you you didn't have a
choice in a situation no one's ever okay
with that it's just the way people are
but it's like that with with every facet
of comic books you know it's not a
racial thing Jane Foster became Thor and
you know what Odin Sun fan said the same
thing that Barry Allen fan said when
Wally West became the flash Oh Jane
Foster sucks Jane Foster's trash Jane
Foster does not need to be Thor
I've been reading Odin's son since
before Ragnarok or maybe there were some
people that read Thor Ragnarok or were
like damn man Thor was dead and then J
michael Straczynski picked up the title
brought Thor back they watched him
recreate Asgard they watched him find
the spiritual essences of all the
Asgardians return them to the normal
bodies they read all that stuff as it
all just kind of progressed and then
suddenly Odin sons gone and Jane fosters
Thor and they felt cheated and they felt
angry because they felt like
all that time and money all that energy
had been invested which is basically
thrown away but comic story had a great
point when he said this only goes so far
diversity is not an inherently bad thing
what you have to do is give people
choices you have to sit a person down
and say here's two titles here's Tony
Stark and here's riri Williams pick
when you want now in my line for me if
one will set me down I said hey Rob
here's a RiRi Williams Ironman title and
here's a Tony Stark Iron Man title which
one do you want to read I'm reading
reread Williams because there's nothing
in that comment book they can tell me
that I probably haven't seen before in
some form or fashion maybe they can and
if I do I'll just kind of skim through
it but my interest will be in riri
Williams I will read that from front to
back
and take my time so it's it's not a
racial thing amadeus cho you know it's
really just about the fact that people
become invested in characters they
become attached to those characters they
watch the characters grow they watch the
mythos grow Mark Waid introduced the
Speed Force Mark Waid basically
established the chronological order of
speedsters talked about how it all came
into existence how it all happened how
speedsters got their powers now Jeff
John's changed a lot of that when he
took over the flash title but the fact
remains that fans were there when they
were learning how the Speed Force
functions that with speedsters it's not
because they were just doused with
chemicals one day and they could run
super fast there's this you know
enigmatic energy force out there that
they draw all their speed from and when
they die they merge with it that's their
heaven that's their afterlife it was it
was great storytelling and they were
there for all that and then now they're
suddenly being told it's not there
anymore you know and so because of that
this is why diversity is really kind of
a big thing is because it's not fans who
are inherently against comic book
changes because of because of race and
so I don't really like the notion of
diversity because what diversity
indicates is that fans are against these
characters because of their because
they're minorities they're against these
characters because they're black or
because you know they're of Asian
orientation or you know because they're
they're a woman or something like that
that's stupid they're against this
change because the characters that you
know and love are suddenly just not
there anymore as it stands right now on
Marvel Comics Peter Parker is the last
man standing he's the last guy who's
spider-man and he know why he's still
spider-man because there's a movie with
him coming out in July so it's it's just
one of those weird things I mean stop
referring to kind of book fans as
racists because they're against
diversity kind of look fans are just
like anybody else
how many book fans are like NFL fans if
somebody had been following the Chicago
Bears for years and years and years and
years only know of they're a team
anymore but they've been following the
Chicago Bears forever and then suddenly
the Bears uprooted and went to a
different City they'd feel betrayed
because they were loyal fans they were
there through thick and thin
it's just like anything else it's just
like anything that people get attached
to they don't want to see a change not
because they're adverse to change but
because they love the character that
they have because they they're attached
to that character they don't want to see
it go away but anyway guys I'm gonna go
ahead and ring this video to in and I
just want to kind of get my two cents
out there I was you know I have a look
to the comments on comic stories video I
imagine there might be some kind of
people who are detractors or something
like that but in truth I stand with with
venting on this one I mean I stand with
comic story I think he's right you know
diversity is not a bad thing in and of
itself it becomes a bad thing when you
don't give people a choice but to read
diversity give people a choice let them
choose what they want to read let them
choose stories they like in the stories
they don't like let them stick with the
characters as they know and love after
all that's why DC rebirth is crushing
Marvel you know if the diversity of
initiative of Marvel Comics was so great
then why their comics selling so poorly
any big guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end and I will catch you all
later peace